cette semaine notre coup de coeur et de
films triple x réactive ait eu avec
wendel thunder qu'edge sportifs de
l'extrême devenu agent d'élite sorte de
l'exil qui s'était imposé pour affronter
le redoutable garnier al fath viande et
son équipe
il entre dans une course impitoyable
afin de récupérer une arme de
destruction massive connue sous le nom
de boîte de pandore la force du film
réside dans son casting de super agent
délirant qu'on imagine tout droit surgi
d'une bande dessinée vinh disent elles
s'éclatent véritablement comme un petit
fou il se lance à la poursuite d'une
arme de destruction massive dans ce
concentré de seine décoiffante
tous les ingrédients sont réunis pour
proposer aux spectateurs un film
d'action survitaminé
il nous faut quelqu'un qui peut plonger
dans une tornade et en ressortir comme
s'il ne s'agissait que d'une vulgaire
petit prise si vous vouliez que je
revienne suffisait de me le demander
triple x réactivité est proposé en
version 2d et 3d est à découvrir cette
semaine à l'espace philippe noiret